[SPEAKER_01]: The evening of the 4th Welsang.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude and Paul, who have been engaging and bragging and challenging each other, discuss what needs to happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have a lot of shit to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so you just said that I look like I haven't slept in days.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's why I'm saying we still have a lot of shit to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're tapped out.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've done great with learning a cantrip.
[SPEAKER_00]: You learned the first one really quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: You couldn't nail down the second one.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's not a big deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you learned one spell a day, you would be better than any initiate in any academy in the known world.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're doing fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: But what I'm also saying is that when shit happens, it doesn't give you a chance to just go tuck into bed and have a nightcap and curl up into your warm sheets.
[SPEAKER_00]: When shit happens in my world, you're trying to stay alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sometimes for days.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, we have shit to do that Jameis or your father, well, sorry, or Prince Gian has asked you to do besides just learning magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I have shit that Lord Jameis has asked me to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: So just because we're done with your arcane training doesn't mean we're done with our shit in the real world.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, I'd like a hundred gold.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I can beat you.
[SPEAKER_00]: How would you like me to prove that I can beat you on who can get closest to the guard?
[SPEAKER_00]: How about this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll kiss him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just gonna use your magic bullshit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You are, like, are you that stupid that you think that I would try to tiptoe up to a guard and kiss him?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I thought the whole premise of this was to just be stealthy and who could get to assist with a guard without being seen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Invisibility's pretty fucking stealthy, wouldn't you say so?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but I also think that's weak.
[SPEAKER_00]: Weak?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you think I'm training you to fucking be?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not weak.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's to use both the arcane arts with your ability to slip a fucking slender blade into somebody's back of their neck.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you can't get behind someone in general, then you shouldn't be...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not a fucking rogue.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not an assassin, so if I can get closer than you...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I get what you're laying down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roll an intelligence check.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a critical fail!
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's a 7, buddy.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a 7.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not a 1.
[SPEAKER_02]: Try again, buddy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to ask this question.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you think Jude is trying to say to me?
[SPEAKER_02]: He wants me to be able to use my abilities that I already have and the abilities he wants to teach me and see how I use them together.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, he is admitting the fact that you probably are better in a lot of things than he is.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if you use his abilities combined with your own, that's unstoppable.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why he asked you about what you think you can do.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when he said invisibility for him is a great power, but when you have the ability to cast invisibility and have anything to dexterity... That's crazy.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is crazy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He can get up to a guard and kiss him.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can get away.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can kiss him and go away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because once I kiss him, I'm going to be like, surprise!
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do we have to do this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you done with the arcane?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we done with this test?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you could actually be...
[SPEAKER_01]: The character that learned amending, you can walk away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like Adrian saying, he'll let you have that cantrip.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, it's an actual, it's a feat.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can develop more.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to learn more.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so he's hooked.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a little bit hooked.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you haven't noticed too- I want to let you know that the assassin mage is one of the most, I mean, it's just fucked up.
[SPEAKER_01]: OP.
[SPEAKER_01]: The player character, it's just like overpowered as the cleric thief.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's what I was saying in Everweave, I'm rolling with a rogue assassin that just went into cleric.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cleric thieves were pretty weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, we've got to learn some shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's only about eight o'clock at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go talk to the...
[SPEAKER_00]: I've already given the recipe for...
[SPEAKER_00]: I've given samples, which I'm not going to get executed for.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank God.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've given samples to the alchemist.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go visit the alchemist.
[SPEAKER_00]: You cool with that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we don't need to go to bed.
[SPEAKER_00]: You still got at least until... You can still get to bed by midnight.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can go...
[SPEAKER_00]: It won't turn into a pumpkin, and you can get up at 7 or 8 o'clock in the morning.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have a fucking bedtime schedule.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're a real dick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least I have a home.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mine's in, like, the Eldorian wood.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've got a frickin' homeless mage here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I left there a long time ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: By the way, you've never heard of the Eldorian wood.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I haven't.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eldorian wood.
[SPEAKER_02]: Some shitty woods.
[SPEAKER_02]: By the way, you've never heard of the Eldorian wood.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just came off this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just made up some shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come on, let's go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we go back to the Alchemist shop, and I go ahead and just knock on, like, if I know that this guy...
[SPEAKER_00]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude and Paul Rivera leave the castle at 8 p.m.